>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, D.C.
>> Talía Guzmán-González:
Bienvenidos.
Good afternoon and welcome
to the Library of Congress.
My name is Talía Guzmán-González,
and I am a reference librarian
[inaudible] Brazilian specialist
in the Hispanic division.
On behalf of the Chief
of the Hispanic division;
Doctor Georgia Dorn
[phonetic] it is my honor
to welcome this distinguished group
of poets from around the world
to the Maratón de Poesía.
The Poetry Marathon or
Maratón de Poesía is led
by its energetic leader
and poet in chief,
Rei Berroa who is celebrating along
with the poets the 25th anniversary
of this important event that I
learned, has been taking place
at the Library of Congress
since 2001.
So, we hope that this
partnership continues
for many years to come, for sure.
I'm going to briefly
introduce Rei Berroa and then,
I'm going to give him the
floor to introduce the poets
and lead the rest of the event.
Rei Berroa was born and raised
in the Dominican Republic
and after traveling, learning
and consuming culture and poetry
from around the world,
he pursued a PHD degree
at the University of Pittsburgh.
He currently teaches contemporary
Spanish and Latin American culture,
literature and literary theory
in the Department of Modern
and Classical Languages at
George Mason University.
He has published over 45 books
of poetry, literary criticism,
anthologies and translations
in several countries throughout
Latin America, Europe, India.
So, all around the world.
Please join me in welcoming
Rei Berroa and the poets
to the Maratón de Poesía.
[ Applauses ]
>> Rei Berroa: That's one of the
privileges of having the marathon is
that you are introduced, and
then you hug and kiss everybody,
and that's the celebration of
brotherhood and sisterhood,
which it's part of what we
are here on this Earth for.
25 años. Yo no sé si eso de bodas
de plata viene precisamente porque
es el momento en que
uno empieza a sentir.
Yo me he recortado el pelo, pero
ahora no se puede ver demasiado,
ahora empieza de repente el
pelo a ponerse de boda de plata.
A platearse.
Voy a hacer una brevísima
introducción del maratón,
antes de -- pero antes
quiero dar las gracias,
darle las gracias a
ustedes por venir aquí,
por estar aquí con nosotros,
dar las gracias a la Biblioteca del
Congreso que siempre nos recibe,
y además, nosotros
contentos de que nos reciban,
y que nos sigan recibiendo
rostros conocidos.
Dar las gracias también,
a los poetas que aceptaron
esta invitación.
Desafortunadamente, los problemas
económicos que nosotros tenemos
influyen también en los poetas,
porque no les podemos pagar su
viaje, su estadía, en vez de eso,
lo que tenemos es un corazón más
grande que el peso que nosotros
llevamos encima.
Algunos lo tienen más grande
que otros, y esto es maravilloso.
Gracias a la oficina cultural
de la Embajada de España,
gracias a la Casa Cultural Salvador,
a la persona de Jeanette Noltenius.
Gracias Catalina, Talía,
Carlos; todos.
Espero, como Talía
acaba de señalar,
que esta hermandad la
continuemos por muchos años.
Por vigésima quinta
vez, bienvenidos, poetas.
Otra vez nos ha cogido
de sorpresa el año,
para recordarnos que esta aventura
que llevamos llamando Maratón de
Poesía del Teatro de la Luna --
[ Aplausos ]
Se inició hace apenas 25 años.
Algunos de ustedes
todavía no habían nacido,
otros estaban quizás, entrando
ya en la adolescencia o su
primera juventud.
[ Risas ]
San Luis, ¿ah?
>> Otros ya éramos viejos.
>> Rei Berroa: Otros, estaban quizá
entrando ya en su adolescencia,
o su primera o segunda juventud.
Había quienes salían
en aquel momento de ella,
y su pelo empezaba a dar señales
de cansancio, y por último,
hubo también quienes presenciaron
nuestra salida del cascaron,
pero no les alcanzo el tiempo
para vernos celebrando estos
entusiasmantes momentos.
Jamás pensé yo, que 25 años
después iba a estar presentando
ésta efeméride.
Pero aquí estamos, luchando hoy
más que nunca para que el humano no
se deje jamás vencer por el miedo
o por la sanguijuela de la mala
política o la mala religión,
o por el poderoso caballero
que es Don Dinero.
En estos días, en que se miente a
plena luz del día desafiando a la
verdad, a que demuestre que tiene
razón de ser en la experiencia
cívica de cada ciudadano.
En estos días de odio abierto
hacia el otro o sus diferencias,
en que un hombre solo con sus
pegajosos acólitos y su constante
cacareo cibernético,
parece convencer a las masas de
que es mejor aislarse que abrirse,
levantar murallas antes
que construir puentes,
insistir en la animosidad, antes
que celebrar la diversidad.
En estos días, repito,
es imprescindible convocar a
nuestra señora, la poesía,
para que irradie su fe en la
humanidad y el sentido común.
Su transparencia y su claridad
sobre la cerrada oscuridad de la
ignorancia que ha sido
desatada contra todos.
Esta es más prístina y crucial
que nunca, la hora cumplida, exacta,
irrevocable de la poesía.
Pueden aplaudir, si quieren.
[ Aplausos ]
Esta es la hora de la poesía.
Voy a señalar una
cuestión logística,
como vamos a llevar a
cabo nuestra lectura.
Nuestros poetas van a venir
a hacer diferentes rondas,
vamos a hacer más o menos
tres rondas la primera vez.
Después, vamos a parar,
vamos a hacer una discusión sobre
la razón de ser de la experiencia
poética en este mundo de hoy, con
sus ventajas y sus desventajas.
Después, vamos a tener unos 10
minutos para hacer una presentación
de una antología que ha
salido ahora en inglés,
antes había salido en español,
"Poetas al pie de la Casa
Blanca", y ¿está Carlos aquí?
Está Luis Alberto Moroño,
Carlos no ha podido venir, bueno.
Le vamos a pedir a Luis Alberto
Moroño en ese momento que venga y
diga unas palabritas sobre
esto, y son unos 10 minutos.
Y después de esto, vamos a regresar
otra vez a la poesía que ustedes
nos han traído.
Le voy a pedir, a cada poeta,
como estamos grabando para
los archivos de la biblioteca,
la primera vez que ustedes
lean, vengan, digan su nombre,
digan sus orígenes y
luego lean su poema.
De la forma en que
ustedes quieran, pero,
eso sí tienen que
hacerlo al principio,
para que sea fácil para los
que preparan la grabación,
que quede constante, pues
después eso va a aparecer allí --
Elena Medel [fonético] de España,
Joao Luís Barreto
Guimaraes, Portugal.
El orden de lectura es el
siguiente; Ricardo Ballón, Bolivia.
Joao Luís Barreto Guimaraes,
Portugal; Mario Bencastro,
El Salvador; Tracy K.
Lewis US; Paraguay.
José Mármol no está aquí por
razones ajenas a su voluntad,
así que yo me voy a permitir el
lujo de subir aquí y decir que yo
soy José Mármol, y voy a leer un
poema de Hochi [fonético] porque la
persona -- una de las personas más
responsables de la celebración de
este maratón es José
Mármol, porque el banco,
todos los años pone el dinero
para que se publique la antología.
El banco donde José trabaja,
y eso se lo debemos a que en el
banco hay un poeta encargado de la
sección de relaciones públicas.
Hacen falta tener más poetas en
otros muchos bancos, a ver si --
Luego de la lectura de
José Mármol, Elena Medel,
luego Balam Rodrigo y por
último Yrene Santos, ¿OK?
Repito, vamos a subir y hacer
rondas de un poema por persona.
Ricardo.
>> Ricardo Ballón: Buenas
tarde, soy Ricardo Ballón,
nací en Bolivia, soy escritor de
poesía y estoy acá para compartir
con ustedes esta experiencia.
Voy a iniciar con un poema que
se llama, "A la vera del camino".
Camino por el cielo y sé que
soy ajeno, camino por la tierra,
y la siento extraña y bella.
No quería llorar, y llovía.
No quería gritar, y los
relámpagos me descubrieron.
Detrás de alguna nube,
yo sé que hay paz,
pero todas están cayendo
y no puedo detenerlas.
No encuentro la salida,
es muy larga la noche,
perdí el día en el camino,
no quiero que el tiempo doble
mis rodillas, necesito un árbol,
una piedra, para sentarme a la vera
del camino y ver por donde paso
la vida.
[ Aplausos ]
>> Solo les quiero
pedir que tal vez,
el que haya coronado
allá en el podio,
porque entonces podemos
interrumpir con el sonido.
>> Exactamente, gracias.
>> La experiencia, señor.
>> Joao Luís Barreto Guimaraes:
Hola a todos, buenas tardes.
Yo soy Joao Luís Barreto
Guimaraes, tengo 50 años,
y vivo y nací en Oporto
en Portugal.
>> O sea, ¿que tenía 25 años
cuando comenzó el maratón?
>> Joao Luís Barreto
Guimaraes: Es verdad.
Yo escribí poemas pequeños
porque voy a leer las dos lenguas.
[ Portugués ]
Vamos a intentar ahora en español.
El gato no quiere movimiento,
largas tardes pasa el
gato revolcado, meditando.
De quien sea el gato espectro,
le toca al gato revelarlo.
La mañana entera ocupado en anular
movimiento, una hojita por el suelo,
la obstinación del viento,
cosas que hagan ruidos o se muevan
insistentes, en su territorio no.
Ruinas alrededor, silencio
dentro del silencio.
El propio tiempo detenido,
para dar ejemplo.
Gracias
[ Aplausos ]
>> Mario Bencastro:
Muy buenas tardes.
Para mi este es un
momento histórico,
porque marca mi regreso
a Washington,
marca mi regreso a ver a Rei
Berroa, a Consuelo Hernández,
a la poetisa querida de
Colombia y a todos mis amigos,
y a la Biblioteca del Congreso, a la
cual vine allá por los años '80.
Y también, marca un
lugar histórico para mí,
porque como Rei acaba de decir,
este es el momento de la poesía.
Y precisamente, este es
el momento en que yo,
los escritores pasan de
la poesía a la prosa,
y yo curiosamente empiezo a
pasar de la prosa a la poesía.
Entonces, es un lugar bastante
apropiado, y un momento apropiado.
Nombre, mi nombre es Mario
Bencastro, vengo de El Salvador.
Así, el libro tiene 16 cantos,
se llama, "Olas del East River",
y no se adapta a estas
presentaciones,
pero yo tampoco me adapto a
las presentaciones, entonces --
pero, es un juego entre poesía,
siguiendo los pasos de Walt Whitman,
y de García Lorca
por el bajo Manhattan.
Tiene un epígrafe de
Walt Whitman, que dice,
"Así como tú te sientes cuando
observas el rio y el cielo,
yo me sentí.
Así como cualquier de ustedes
es uno de la multitud, yo fui.
Así como a ti te refresca la
alegría del rio y la brillante
corriente, me refresco a mí".
Entonces, el East River me refresco
a mi cuando yo trabajaba en Wall
Street, y de ahí nació este
poemario que se divide en 16 cantos,
y en cada ronda voy a leer uno,
y este es el canto número uno.
El East River irrefrenable viajero,
enhebra su piel con
ondulaciones de espuma,
un secreto entusiasmo guía sus
aguas desde la época glacial,
siempre adelante, persistente,
incansable.
En sus entrañas transparentes,
acarrea historias, destinos,
al compás de un incesante coro
monocorde que emana de sus húmedos
labios azules.
Costas, árboles, rocas, barcos
hacen valla a su paso sinuoso,
suave, cadencioso, firme,
mensajero de burbujas, peces, ranas,
misivas con signos extraños,
acaso de amor, acaso de nada.
A un lado del rio, yace Brooklyn,
hogar para cualquiera,
de cualquier lugar.
Opuesto, se irgue Manhattan,
la isla que intoxica.
Canjeada los Lenapes por 24 monedas,
trato que fundó Wall Street,
donde poderes suben y bajan,
fortunas vienen y van
como las olas del río.
La corriente trae a Nueva
York vidas, fletes, dichas,
desdichas de rincones lejanos.
Franceses vinieron, seguidos de
holandeses, ingleses, italianos,
españoles, latinoamericanos.
Del fondo broto libertad,
diosa monumental,
alumbrando su antorcha
hacia los desterrados,
"Dadme vuestros rendidos,
vuestros pobres".
El rio, vio erigir rascacielos
hasta opacar la bóveda celeste,
y desplomarse hechos cenizas.
Los que unos construyen en
años, otros destruyen en horas.
Humana e inhumana es la especie
considerada superior del planeta.
Todo es relegado al archivo fluvial,
y contado en el idioma de las olas,
a su paso bajo los puentes
Brooklyn, Manhattan, y Williamsburg.
En el líquido espejo del rio,
el cielo maquilla su rostro con
algodones blancos de nubes y
retoques de tintes azules.
Los atardeceres ablandan
el alma del sol,
y éste pinta las almas con
brochazos dorados parodiando
al banco.
Gracias.
[ Aplausos ]
>> Tracy K. Lewis: Yo soy Tracy
K. Lewis, único gringo aquí.
Nací en Estados Unidos,
me crie en Estados Unidos,
pero me apasioné por la
poesía Latinoamericana,
y en particular de Paraguay.
Y también, soy abuelo nuevo,
y en honor a mi nuevo nieto
que está aquí con nosotros --
>> Saluda a la multitud.
>> Tracy K. Lewis: Louie John
[fonético] y mi querida hija Megan,
su madre.
Mi señora Audrey, y
mi yerno eterno Drew.
Escribí este poema --
Para el pequeño Louie John que
entro al mundo el 31 de enero
de 2017.
Al nacer, nieto mío, sin saber
reanudaste el antiguo ciclo de todo
lo redondo y duro, el puño
diminuto de tu coronilla empapada,
forzando rumbo de entrada
entre manos de partera,
para luego volverte
todo suave y arrullos.
Pequeño planeta a
flote en mis brazos.
Naciste único, Louie.
Y, sin embargo, gemelo
eres de tu madre,
quien a su vez floto
también en mis brazos.
Planeta de anhelos y promesas,
mía entera, y en pañales.
Pero pasa de pronto algo
raro; el que nace soy yo.
Me siento de pronto hecho puño,
encuclillarme, aupar entre,
ante el ruedo sonante de
luz al final de lo negro,
para luego brotar en otra orbita,
enmantado en manos sonrientes.
Planeta también, ¿En brazos
de que otro me acompañas tú?
[ Aplausos ]
>> Rei Berroa: Yo soy Rei Berroa,
pero voy a leer un
poema de José Mármol,
que no ha podido estar
aquí en este momento,
por situaciones ajenas
a su voluntad.
José Mármol, de la
Republica Dominicana.
Indocumentados.
Tiene un epígrafe de Ernesto Maes
Vallenilla [fonético] que dice,
"Y nuestro ser más íntimo consiste
en un esencial y reiterado no ser,
siempre, todavía."
Hijos del fondo, de humilde regazo,
del barrio otoñal y de parcos
almacenes que antologaron noches.
Hijos del canto metálico
de aguaceros de mayo,
y del mágico estallar de
cimientos para el lodo.
Hijos de la utopía nacida y varada
en los peces y pájaros que abrevan
en su olvido.
De calles polvorientas con perpetuas
lunarias hogareñas del desamparo,
de la incertidumbre, de
materia de nostalgia y jubileo.
Hijos de pardos celadores
del tono de la niebla,
de maestros albañiles y audaces
artesanos, de oficinistas tiernas,
de antiguos combatientes en abril.
Estación de la sangre
y los caminos.
Hijos de seres imaginarios
ya encarnados.
Hijos de los hijos de unos hombres,
nacidos y muertos en dos lados.
Herederos de un decálogo secreto,
inscrito en el exacerbo
infeliz de la memoria,
de un aire matinal
con aroma a bullicio,
con pasos recorriendo huellas en la
humedad del sopor de la cuaresma.
Todo el tiempo herederos, idéntico
al párrafo entristeciendo a tientas
y llorando la canción
del Evangelio.
Hijos de un ayer que no
vislumbro entonces ni pasado,
tal vez, ni por venir.
Esclavos de un ahora tenso,
y de un impredecible camino de
retorno del que nunca se sabrá si
corto, o más largo.
Si prodigo en riquezas
en sabiduría,
o una sorda historia de
olvido y desencuentro.
[ Aplausos ]
>> Elena Medel: Hola, yo me llamo
Elena Medel, y vengo de España.
Quería dar las gracias a Rei por
la invitación a participar en el
maratón, y también a la Oficina
Cultural de la Embajada de España,
que hace posible que
este yo aquí hoy.
Árbol genealógico.
Yo pertenezco a una raza de mujeres
con el corazón biodegradable.
Cuando una de nosotras muere,
reciben su cadáver en
los parques públicos.
Los niños se acercan para curiosear
en su garganta de hojalata.
Se celebran, se tiñen
con mosca y gusano.
Me cae mal, porque me hizo
sonreír a mí, que soy tan triste.
A los 30 días exactos de su muerte,
el cuerpo de esta extraordinaria
raza se autodestruye.
Y a las puertas de vuestras casas,
llaman los restos del alma de
las mujeres sobrenaturales,
chocan contra vuestras paredes.
Sus empastes y sus uñas
agujerean vuestras ventanas,
hasta que sangran nuestras
aortas clavadas en la tierra,
igual que las raíces.
Al morir, nos abren el estómago,
examinan con los dedos su interior.
Rebuscan entre las vísceras el mapa
del tesoro, sacan su dedo negro,
vetados los poemas que se nos
han quedado dentro con los años.
Un espectáculo.
Pertenezco a una raza, desarrollada
más allá de los pulpitos.
Soy una de ellas porque mi corazón
mancha al tomarlo entre las manos,
porque coincide en tamaño
con el hueco de un nicho.
Fresco y dulce, como el de un
animal, chupad mi corazón,
para que al morir sepan
que hemos estado juntos.
Soy una de ellas, porque
mi corazón será abono,
porque mi sangre que es la suya,
sube y baja por mi cadáver
como por escaleras mecánicas.
Porque el fundamento de mi
carácter, al descomponerse,
se incorpora una especie de
salvaje que ladra, y que hiere,
y que te lleva a su terreno,
que ignora las afrentas,
que jamás se extinguirá.
Gracias.
[ Aplausos ]
>> Balam Rodrigo: Yo
soy Balam Rodrigo.
Originario de Villa de
Comaltitlán, Chiapas, México.
Sermón del migrante.
Bajo un árbol de ceiba.
Y dios también estaba en el
exilio, migrando sin término.
Viajaba montado en
el tren la bestia,
y no había sufrido crucifixión, si
no mutilación de piernas, brazos.
Mudo y cenizo todo él, mientras
caía en cruz desde lo alto de
los cielos.
Arrojado por los malandros,
desde las negras nubes del tren,
desde vagones laberinticos sin fin.
Y vi claro como sus costillas eran
atravesadas por la lanza circular de
los narcotraficantes,
de los policías,
por la bayoneta de los militares,
por la lengua en extorsión.
Y era su sufrimiento tan grande como
el de todos los migrantes juntos,
es decir, el dolor de cualquiera.
Antes, mientras estaba el
señor en Centroamérica,
en esa pequeña Belén, en
la esquina rota del mundo,
nos decía en su sermón
del domingo,
mientras bautizaba a los
desterrados, a los expatriados,
a los sin tierra, a los pobres, en
las aguas del agonizante rio Lempa.
"El que quiera seguirme a Estados
Unidos que deje su familia y
abandone las Maras, la
violencia, el hambre, la miseria.
Que olvide a los infames caciques
y oligarcas de Centroamérica,
y sígame", y aun mientras caía,
aun antes de las mutilaciones,
antes de que lo llevaran
al médico hecho pedazos,
para ser enterrado en una fosa
común como a cualquier otro
Centroamericano, como a los cientos
y miles de migrantes que cada año
mueren asesinados en México.
Mientras caía con los brazos y las
piernas en forma de cruz antes de
llegar al suelo, antes de cortar
su carne las ruedas de óxido de la
bestia, antes de que su bendita
sangre tiñera las varias coronas de
espinas que ruedan sobre los rieles
clavados con huesos a la espalda del
Imperio Mejica.
El señor recordó en visiones a
su discípulo Francisco Morazán,
y le dio un beso en la mejilla,
y tomo un puñado de tierra
centroamericana y ungió con ella su
corazón y su lengua, y recordó
que Morazán le pregunto una vez,
mientras yacían bajo la
sombra de un árbol de ceiba,
aquella en la que había hecho
el milagro de multiplicar el
aguardiente y las tortillas.
"Maestro, ¿Qué debemos hacer
si nos detienen y nos deportan?"
A lo que el señor respondió,
"Deben migrar 70 veces siete,
y si ellos les piden los
dólares y los vuelven a deportar,
denles la capa, la
mochila, la botella de agua,
los zapatos y sacudan
el polvo de sus pies,
y vuelvan a migrar nuevamente
de Centroamérica y de México,
sin voltear a ver más nunca atrás"
[ Aplausos ]
>> Yrene Santos: Muy buenas
tardes, es imposible para mí,
pararme aquí y no agradecerle a Rei
Berroa por esta gran oportunidad.
Es la primera vez que estoy
en la Biblioteca del Congreso,
y para mí es un honor.
Yrene Santos, de la
Republica Dominicana,
vivo en Nueva York hace 25 años.
>> Cuando comenzó el maratón.
>> Yrene Santos: Cuando
comenzó el maratón.
>> Apenas llegó.
>> Yrene Santos: El
incansable juego.
Las 2a.m., las 3a.m., es
la madrugada de siempre,
con sus mismas curvas de desvelo.
El lápiz juega su último punto
en la puntiaguda palabra que
me sorprende.
Las 3a.m. Las 3.12a.m., cada quien
sueña con todo lo ocurrido durante
el día.
El incansable juego, el
bullicio de los niños,
las interminables idas
a un mostrador ajeno,
las huidas escurridizas del asombro,
los largos pasillos por
donde transita la memoria,
los cuerpos encorvados
de las frustraciones.
Mi talón de Aquiles, el cansancio
de José, la sorpresa, la pereza,
los bostezos, la indiferencia, la
fe, las oraciones, las reuniones.
Las cuatro.
Las cuatro y 34.
Me vuelvo hacia la pared.
Ansiosa espero la palabra,
la que no me alcanza,
esa que quema, la de
todos los días.
Muchas gracias.
[ Aplausos ]
>> Ricardo Ballón:
Un día cualquiera.
El día abrió sus alas como
dóciles páginas blancas.
Las calles despejadas comenzaron a
llenarse de pasos, unos apurados,
otros desesperados,
y muchos perdidos.
Ahí estaban los árboles, quietos,
con los ojos abiertos entre el
murmullo de las ramas y el rumor de
la gente.
[ Aplausos ]
>> Joao Luís Barreto
Guimaraes: Problema de física.
[ Portugués ]
Problema de física.
Si el ave Málaga-Córdoba
avanza a 300 por hora,
las colinas derramando
cascadas de casas modéjares,
yo avanzo hacia el Bagan Bar
[fonético] a dos kilómetros por
hora sobre la tierra
andaluza, olivares inmortales.
¿Con que prisa el corazón corre,
poder contemplar los platos
floridos de las fiestas?
¿Las afiladas callejeras árabes,
los arcos sepia de la catedral?
A, 150 kilómetros por hora; B,
600 kilómetros por hora; o C,
302 kilómetros por hora.
Ustedes contestar.
[ Aplausos ]
>> Mario Bencastro: Bueno, como
Olas del East River tiene 16 cantos,
tengo la oportunidad de
dedicar un canto a cada amigo.
Entonces, en esta ocasión la
dedico a Allison Lima [fonético],
profesora del Montgomery College,
que estudia -- enseña a mí ahora,
a los muchachos del
Montgomery College.
Este tiene un epígrafe
de T.S Elliot, que dice,
"No sé mucho de dioses, pero
creo que el río es un fuerte dios
broncíneo, hosco,
salvaje e intratable.
El río está dentro de nosotros, y
yo creo que este río, este poema,
es la memoria del rio
que quedo en mi".
El canto número dos, dice, "La
corriente me trajo del mar".
Atado a los grilletes del desierto,
es en un velero llamado destino.
Alucinado, llegué
al bajo Manhattan,
un accista me extendió
tres acciones.
Cotizan fortuna, drama y fe.
Trácalas según tu criterio, ganes
o pierdas, tu deber es invertirlas.
Seguir la muralla contra el sol,
rostros veían con cuencas vacías,
dibujaban sonrisas automáticas,
disparaban saludos pregrabados.
En las esquinas vigilaban sombras,
en las aceras iban veloces mil pies.
Voces compraban y vendían
fortunas infladas de papel.
"Bienvenido", dijo un
vagabundo, "¿Qué rumbo tomamos?
¿Buscas oro brillante, dramas
resonantes o el poder de la fe?
Tú decides, aquí
todo tiene su precio",
como pregonan especuladores en
vitrinas y tiendas de rascacielos
rompe nubes.
En los andenes pululan mendigos,
antiguos capitalistas cantando sus
trágicos blues sobre amor y dinero,
ganado y perdido, con
voz de ruiseñores.
Predicadores abren sus biblias
gritando oscuras profecías,
que no crispan la piel
de sordos apostadores.
El semáforo indica caminar, la
estatua de Washington, invertir.
Cincelados en la puerta de
la Iglesia de la Trinidad,
Adán y Eva lloran su
expulsión del Edén,
condenados a peregrinar por
los intestinos de la bolsa.
¿Libreto para Broadway?
¿Oportunidad comercial?
Un policía increpa a una vagabunda,
"Levántate y anda",
yo sigo sus pasos.
Gracias.
[ Aplausos ]
>> Tracy K. Lewis: Este poema va
dedicado a los millares de personas
anónimas, a veces, que realmente
hacen funcionar esta ciudad.
Se titula inmigrante.
Para Otilia Cortes [fonético],
solito con voz en compañera.
Me esfuerzo, isla latina,
en océano sajón,
atolón de arrecife
precario contra papas sosas,
el brillo hipócrita de los dientes.
Difícil ante tanto anglo
monosílabo de cajero,
armar mis lotes de
erres y guitarras.
Mi piropo sincero al
mundo y sus nalgas,
¿Quién fuera sillón, mi reina?
¿Quién fuera seda?
Difícil la picardía de palmera,
frente al rictus de las paredes.
Tal vez venga el apocalipsis,
tal vez se invierta el mapa,
el sur sea chingón y no chingada,
el Tío Sam se moje la espalda,
Donald Trump se rompa el culo
cortando coles en Chiapas,
la Migra se vuelva Madre Teresa.
Tal vez este piso que
limpio hable español,
las mesas sucias y las lechugas,
y los orinales y los
surcos de pesticida,
y los mataderos de cerdos nos
griten, "Buen trabajo, buen trabajo,
buen trabajo hermano"
¿Quién fuera isla, hermano?
[ Aplausos ]
>> Elena Medel: Un cuervo
en la ventana del Rey Van
Carver [fonético].
Nadie se posa en el alfeizar, son 28
años de espacio adolescente, pero,
¿qué ocurriría si el pájaro
sobre el que he leído en todos los
poemas se colara por
el patio de luces,
y asomara por el alfeizar
de mis 28 años?
Un pájaro en mi habitación
adolescente.
Y, ¿qué ocurriría
si yo escribiese aun?
Si me preguntan, respondo,
"Que ya no".
Y un pájaro cualquiera.
Ninguno de los pájaros sobre los
que haya leído en todos los poemas;
un cuervo, o una de las palomas
negras que asoman en la oficina,
interrumpiesen la escritura como
el que se posó en la ventana
de Carver.
Ganaría su lugar en el poema,
dejaría de ser pájaro,
alza el vuelo, ya no hay
habitación en el alfeizar.
Gracias.
[ Aplausos ]
>> Balam Rodrigo: Bueno,
para cambiar un poco el tono y
seguir con un poco los poemas
dedicados a este lugar.
A partir de una fotografía de Diane
Arbus [fonético] de Jorge Luis
Borges, este poema.
Solo los ciegos sueñan con el sol.
Sueñan en negativo, de ahí que el
sol de sus visiones derrame siempre
una luz negra, y en el
reino de la gran manzana,
donde la inmensa muchedumbre tiene
ciego el corazón, Diane Arbus,
la gran tuerta del ojo
mecánico es la reina.
Ella sueña también con el sol.
Ese gran sexo abierto y
goteante, ahogado en el cielo.
Borges soñó con el mismo sol,
un sol decapitado que derramaba
la dura luz de su cuello,
en chorros de sílabas infinitas,
guiños de un aleph
[fonético] innombrable.
El iris balanceado por los
cuervos de plata de la fotografía,
Diane Arbus y su largo
graznido de luz.
Lenguas de nieve lamen el corazón
y lo incendian a la hora en la que
oscuros gallos o negros álamos
decapitan a la luna con sus ramas o
crestas, olas de mar en
llamas, parvadas de oro rojo,
báculos de sangre yugular en que
se apoya Borges frente a la cámara.
Cría ojos verdaderos, y te
sacaran los cuervos del corazón.
[ Aplausos ]
>> Yrene Santos: La mujer.
Hoy he visto una mujer
llorándole los huesos,
en ellos los recuerdos se
aposentan, entretejen su sueño,
tan estropeado como sus pies.
Sus manos, sus senderos de carne,
mientras cabizbaja sus ojos
cerrados se deslizan a la tierra,
su espalda semidesnuda piensa
rumores de los años vividos.
Las memorias se pierden
con el hambre,
el hambre catapulta
cualquier gesto de alegría,
hoy he visto a una mujer envuelta en
un rosado hasta donde comienzan sus
dos rumbos, con la cabeza cansada
y su pelo de una pulgada tocando su
vientre ancho, y las rodillas
en un escalo cualquiera,
de una estación del tren.
Muchos pies menos a esta hora
arrastran la fatiga de un
día largo.
Menos y menos pies -- dedos y
menos pies afincan la ternura que
instantes atrás, rozaron
brazos, muslos,
vientres o se geometrizaron
en un agudo fastidio,
una cama caliente o un suelo fresco.
Y a esa mujer, hoy en mi cartera me
la he traído para mantenerla viva,
digna, plena, en una
habitación de mis libreros.
Gracias.
[ Aplausos ]
>> Ricardo Ballón: Del Diario de
la Sombra, voy a leer un poema.
Ayer vi tu rostro estrujado
por el tiempo.
Entre los espejos rotos
de la lluvia.
Escuche el crujir de tus promesas
en los viejos maderos durmientes,
eras mi fantasma preferido,
con el que jugaba de niño,
corríamos de la mano en ese
bosque embrujado de la inocencia,
hasta que un día nuestros
pasos se perdieron.
Fui el rehén de la
espera y el olvido,
disfruté con las fieras y las
aves de rapiña cada pedazo de
amor caído.
Entre las hojas, temblando de miedo,
aún guardo los retazos de
aquellos días parados de puntas,
buscando aparecidos.
[ Aplausos ]
>> Joao Luís Barreto Guimaraes:
Este poema se llama,
¿Puede ser Pepsi?
[ Portugués ]
Vamos a intentar.
¿Puede ser Pepsi?
Me gusta ver jeroglíficos en
las suelas de las gaviotas,
no me gusta que los días de
fiesta caigan en fin de semana.
Me gustan los frescos de Pompeya
en los días de más calor,
no me gusta nada que los
griegos mezclen agua en el vino.
Prefiero los héroes sin nombre,
al nombre de los grandes héroes.
Distingo el dolor de
los que pierden,
de la total perdida del dolor.
Me gusta sentir la música
de vuelta a mi vida,
no me gusta el Mediterráneo,
transformado en cementerio.
Prefiero el fondo del alma
a los fondos de inversión.
Distingo la liquidez de los
bancos, de la liquidez de los ojos.
Me gusta una ensalada
Cesar en una plaza de Roma,
no me gusta pedir Coca Cola
y oír, ¿puede ser Pepsi?
Gracias.
[ Aplausos ]
>> Mario Bencastro:
También [inaudible].
Este es el canto número tres,
y ahora le toca a Jeanette
Noltenius ser dedicada.
Jeanette Noltenius es la
fundadora de la Casa de la Cultura,
patrocinadora del Teatro de la Luna,
y patrocinadora de este evento.
Muchas gracias por abrir su
corazón y su apartamento.
Gracias.
Tiene un epígrafe que dice,
"Por el East River y el Bronx,
los muchachos cantaban mostrando sus
cinturas, con la rueda, el aceite,
el cuero y el martillo",
esto es Federico García Lorca
en su oda a Walt Whitman.
Canto número tres.
La calle vibra en su punto crucial.
Un grafiti anuncia un nuevo
mesías, otro, el fin del mundo.
Misioneros exhortan arrepentimiento,
periódicos declaran la guerra,
justifican la tortura,
esclavitud, hambre.
Son gastos colaterales de la paz.
Proclaman muerta a la utopía, y
el consumismo la nueva libertad.
Alguien pregunta, "¿Qué
paso con los poetas?
¿Qué paso con la poesía?
¿A dónde fueron los poetas, a
eructar sus versos aguardentosos?
Esos paladines de la palabra,
brillantes trasnochados,
infladores de egos, miembros
de clubes de aduladores mutuos,
lo sé", dice, "Porque
yo soy uno de ellos",
¿están los poetas más
allá del bien y del mal?
Carteles anuncian nuevos modelos de
dioses para toda ocasión y vanidad.
Y la globalización del llanto.
Los parlantes vociferan, "El
mercado subió 100 puntos."
Mil ventanas se abren
en Wall Street,
estruendo de aplausos,
vomitan los rascacielos.
Gracias.
[ Aplausos ]
>> Tracy K. Lewis: Como
la política, también,
el futbol puede ser
fuente de poesía.
Este poema contiene
alguna alusión, también,
a la historia de Paraguay y la
lamentable guerra de la Triple
Alianza, en la que Paraguay perdió
gran parte de su población y mucho
territorio también.
Argentina cinco, Paraguay dos.
Ronda eliminatoria, torneo Copa
del Mundo, 10 septiembre, 2013.
¿Podés vencerme en fútbol?
Mandarme al carajo con
mi equipaje a cuestas.
Joderme en una guerra o 10.
Cercenarme pulgar o testículo,
quitarme techo, piel, o Iguazú.
Obligarme a contar
ombligos de banqueros,
embadurnarme la corbata
en cacas o chismes.
Defecarme en la oreja, llamarme
estúpido, guarango, yanqui,
come mierda, mal amante, mal poeta.
Escupirme, maldecirme,
servirme comida de avión,
ahogarme en mayonesa, aguarme
la cerveza, pero negarme no,
este tango de brisas en los
dedos astrales de la noche.
[ Aplausos ]
>> Elena Medel: Estamos
realizando obras en el exterior,
no utilizar esta puerta,
ese trancazo de emergencia.
Madurar era esto, no caer al
suelo, chocar contra el suelo,
contemplar el pudrirse de la
piel igual que un fruto antiguo.
Colchón justo para los dos,
años que chocan la lengua contra
los dientes una y otra vez,
que se tambalean en la boca.
Año de sentido incorrecto.
Contra hilos de cabeza
he tejido mi tiempo.
Piensa en vosotros a mi edad,
piensa en tres hilos de cabeza
que te falta, que te queda.
Piensa en tres hilos,
quizá eso, madurar.
Quizá Ulises boca abajo,
quizá la orilla boca arriba.
Eso que queréis me
esperara 10 años.
Pensad en días caída, pensad
en diez hilos de cabeza, aquello,
la madurez, marcha te,
olor a lava-vajilla.
Déjame con mi sueño, o quizá
en la boca uvas para el postre del
color, de la rodilla
que cae al suelo,
de la rodilla que choca
contra el suelo.
Me tambaleo, y era yo el zumo
en la garganta, era yo el frio,
era yo las uñas y el estómago.
¿Quién era yo en
mis años con tres,
en mi tiempo con diez
hilos de cabeza?
Hasta mi habitación, por
mi escalera de incendios,
un hombre y su sentido contrario.
Diez hilos de cabeza, veinte hilos
de su pecho atados a mi pecho.
Juro que ame los golpes
de sus piernas.
Digo que madurar era
esto, que no pude negarme,
digo que mis tres hilos
de nada entre mis dedos.
Y jure chocar y el suelo, lo jure.
Pensé, "Al suelo la caída,
y el choque contra el suelo",
pensé el aliento, pensé, dije
tres hilos de cabeza, tambaleo.
Pensé en mi edad y
pensé en vosotros.
Y pensé que nadie me
aviso de madurar así,
junto a la vida y el frio en el
cajón de la fruta que se pudre.
Gracias.
[ Aplausos ]
>> Balam Rodrigo: Bueno,
aquí tienen al Balam,
el vasallo de este rey.
Anti-Ícaro.
Anti-Ícaro, no quise
yo volar, si no caer.
Por eso escribo, para
dejar de soñar,
para dejar el vuelo a los
pájaros y a la memoria.
Pero heme aquí, con luengas alas,
urdidas en el polvo del sueño y
ataviadas con el plumaje del tiempo
sin el tiempo, por eso escribo,
para caer y apuntalar con
estas letras mi cuerpo,
y forzarlo a descender
en esta página,
tatuada ya por el peso
todo de mi sangre.
Y así, desleído y cercenadas mis
alas con el filo de tus parpados,
yace mi cuerpo desangrado
entre renglones;
caído, terrestre, soberbio.
Y aun señalado por
el dédalo de dios,
y la niña de tus ojos
que traza en mi destino.
Anti-Ícaro, no quieres
tu volar, si no leer.
[ Aplausos ]
>> Yrene Santos: De rumba me voy.
De rumba me voy, con el
sí, posiblemente acordado.
Allá me espera quien sabes,
la palabra que por años me
provee esta felicidad en el papel.
En la pared manchada de grafitis,
en las bolsas del supermercado.
Ya sabes. Así soy, un poco loca.
La sensatez desgarra las horas.
La seriedad en los rostros
mortifica el esplendor de mi risa.
De niña, he sido aspavientosa.
Quien creería en estos
miedos de ahora.
Estas palpitaciones
frente al público,
estas ganas de que la tierra
me trague con su boca grande,
mojada de siglos.
¿Quién creería en mis insomnios?
A los que espero con
los brazos abiertos,
mis uñas pálidas y
mis ojos agonizantes.
De rumba me voy.
Merengué con sabor a Cibao.
Boleros de Beltrán, Perico Ripiado,
Bachatas llorando en el suelo.
Pero, sobre todo estaremos nosotros,
los que entonces, los que antes,
los que llegarán sin ser vistos,
mientras las líneas
extenderán su vuelo.
El dolor calando en las esquinas,
su sabor al sentir me plena,
al sentirme entendida, condenada,
alocada o profundamente dormida,
porque en el sueño,
me volví poesía.
Muchas gracias.
[ Aplausos ]
>> Rei Berroa: Bueno, vamos
a hacer nuestra primera --
nuestro primer descanso.
Pero, no vamos a descansar, pues
tenemos que seguir pensando.
Yo les voy a proponer -- antes
de entrar en esta discusión,
quiero recordarles a todos que mis
estudiantes de George Mason publican
una revista cada año, y han
traído copias a la mesa que esta
allá afuera.
Oh, ¿están aquí ya?
Entonces, si alguno de ustedes
quiere llevarse una copia,
y además saber, pueden llevarse
un par de ellas si quieren.
Y además, no se olviden que es una
revista que es revisada por pares,
es decir, que los estudiantes y
los profesores revisan para aceptar
los textos.
Que si quieren llevarse su copia,
pueden tranquilamente llevarse la
suya, y enviar textos a la revista.
Miren lo que vamos a hacer,
porque me han dicho que la
discusión va a tener que llevarse a
cabo de esta forma; yo voy a
proponer un tema para abrir la
reflexión y cada persona
que quiera participar,
tiene que venir a hablar
desde aquí,
porque me han dicho que el
micrófono este es el micrófono que
capta la discusión.
Es decir, que en el
momento en que haya --
que alguien quiera participar,
viene aquí, hace su presentación,
si hacemos una discusión, pues las
dos personas van a estar aquí en la
discusión, ¿me entienden?
Quisiera aclarar eso
para crear una dinámica.
Y quiero abrir de esta manera.
¿Cuál es la tradición de la
poesía en el mundo occidental en el
que nosotros nos movemos?
¿Cuáles son los compromisos
que como poetas,
nosotros asumimos o
tenemos que asumir?
¿Con quién?
¿Con quiénes?
¿A quién respondemos nosotros?
Si es que respondemos a alguien,
en el momento de plasmar en el papel
una serie de ideas o reflexiones que
nos van a mover en
una dirección u otra.
Es decir, ¿asume la
poesía hoy un compromiso?
¿Cuál es ese compromiso?
¿Quiénes están involucrados
en ese compromiso?
O, ¿qué implica ese compromiso?
Que nosotros pensamos
que es válido o no.
Realmente la poesía realmente no
tiene ningún tipo de compromiso,
y nos tenemos que preguntar, como
se preguntaba Mario hace un rato,
y los poetas, ¿Dónde
están, que hacen?
Es esa mi primera cuestión.
¿Alguien quiere tomar la palabra?
Y moverse -- sí, Mario.
>> Mario Bencastro: Creo que anoche,
con Joao empezamos
esta discusión, ¿no?
Por televisión y por radio.
Nos preguntamos, por ejemplo --
bueno, podríamos usar el
epígrafe de Roque Dalton, que dice,
"Perdóname poesía, por haberte
demostrado que no estás hecha solo
de palabras."
Entonces, anoche,
es bien interesante
porque nos preguntábamos,
¿qué paso con la poesía?
¿A dónde se fue?
¿Se fue a las alturas?
Y, ¿por qué la poesía es
menos popular hoy que antes?
¿Por qué en América Latina,
la poesía es como una necesidad?
Que de ahí, Pablo Neruda
y, ¿por qué de pronto,
la poesía como que se fue por las
palabras y se olvidó de la tierra?
¿No? Entonces, con Joao; el leía
su poesía, que era una perspectiva,
y yo leía no la poesía que
estoy leyendo esta noche, si no,
una poesía como la de Balam,
que me pareció muy
acertada en ese sentido.
Es un -- o sea, me parece que la
poesía ha agarrado diferentes
perspectivas, pero no sé porque,
ahora la gente piensa que
la poesía no es necesaria.
Yo estoy pasando por ese momento,
porque estoy en la transición de
la prosa, de la novela a la poesía,
y siento la gran diferencia
de redacción.
Por ejemplo, la Mansión del Olvido,
mi última novela, se podría decir,
como decía García Márquez;
"Se vende como longanizas", ¿no?
Sin embargo, el libro
de poesías nada.
No se oye, no.
Entonces, ¿cuál es la diferencia?
¿Por qué?
Y que la poesía ha perdido
esa -- ha perdido su valor,
o su perspectiva, o
se ha desnaturalizado,
como que ya no es parte de nosotros.
Como que fuera, la pusieron en un
altar y los que no tienen acceso a
ese altar ya no pueden
acceder a ella.
>> Rei Berroa: Ya.
Es decir, hay un valor que
le asignamos a la poesía.
Hace un tiempo, en la Feria del
Libro de la Republica Dominicana,
conversando con uno de los
poetas jóvenes que me dijo,
"¿tienes algún libro?", le digo,
"sí, he dejado algún libro ahí",
"¿no me vas a regalar uno?"
porque obviamente, los primeros
que no compran la poesía,
somos los poetas.
>> Mario Bencastro: Exacto.
>> Rei Berroa: Pareciera como que
estamos esperando que los poetas nos
entreguen su trabajo
gratis, ¿por qué?
Porque hasta cierto punto --
quizá es porque no tiene ningún
valor a los ojos el hecho --
a los ojos del lector, el hecho de
que, "Ah, te dedicas a escribir".
Si tu estas, tu si vas y compras
una novela o un libro de cuentos,
pero si es un libro de poemas,
tenemos la idea de que el poeta
tiene que regalarnos ese libro
de poemas.
Y esto es problemático, porque
el valor que se le asigna en la
ciudadanía a la poesía es muy
diferente al valor que se le asigna
a otro tipo de creación.
Y además, el poeta tiene que estar
gozoso y feliz de haber creado un
texto hermoso, con las
palabras de todos los días.
Como el carpintero está realmente
emocionado de haber terminado su
mesa, o el arquitecto.
Y, ¿por qué, cual es el problema
que tiene la sociedad de hoy,
con respecto a la poesía?
¿Hay una salida para
esto, para los poetas?
Ok, sí. Una y dos.
>> No necesariamente es el
punto de vista de un poeta,
pero de una persona que lo estudia.
Yo era pequeña, yo sabía
que amaba la poesía,
porque me la enseno mi abuelo.
Y cuando yo estaba en la clase,
yo vi que no había mucha gente
que quería aprender la poesía,
porque lo encontraba
demasiado difícil.
Y era la misma cosa
con los profesores,
aunque ellos lo querían era
bueno -- esta es la poesía,
y ellos quieren decir esto.
Y si los estudiantes no lo podían
entender, no lo querían leer.
Y mucha gente no lo entiende.
Entonces, van a la prosa,
o van a las novelas.
Y por eso, desaparece ese valor,
pero no es que no tiene valor,
porque cuando lo entiendes
o lo quieres leer,
es algo tan importante
y que puedes --
como es el alma de una
persona, y es tan grande.
No sé, pero esto es de una
persona que lo estudia y que lo ama.
Entonces, no se --
[ Aplausos ]
>> Bueno, felizmente la poesía
no se vende, gracias a dios.
Pero, es increíble y sorpresivo,
como la poesía que toca el
inconsciente de la humanidad,
como voz del pueblo, vuela.
En mi caso, por ejemplo,
se ha convertido en una canción que
uso un presidente en una campaña
presidencial, el título del
poema, "Dame el pan, Argentina",
escrita aquí en los Estados Unidos.
O se convierte, por
ejemplo, en Facebook,
en una serie de traducciones
visuales totalmente inesperadas.
O, por ejemplo, un poema
titulado, "Narco Plegaria",
parece un volumen el problema de
la droga en los Estados Unidos,
publicado en Dinamarca.
Entonces, esa es la
virtud que tiene el poema,
esa economía del lenguaje, esa
brevedad en tocar a la humanidad,
y cuando realmente la toca,
de algún modo se recrea.
Viva la poesía.
[ Aplausos ]
>> Tracy K. Lewis: Voy
a decir algo muy breve.
Pero, para mí, yo
creo que la poesía,
lo que hace es llevarnos
al umbral del misterio.
Pero, a diferencia de otras
actividades humanas, por ejemplo,
la ciencia, la investigación
científica.
Por ejemplo, nos lleva -- la poesía
nos lleva al umbral del misterio,
pero no pretende explicar
el misterio.
Respeta el misterio,
celebra el misterio.
Y yo creo que eso es lo que
distingue la poesía de otros
géneros de actividad,
creatividad humana, para mí.
>> Balam Rodrigo: Si, bueno.
Algo que quisiera agregar tiene que
ver con lo que está sucediendo en
todo el mundo, no solo de habla
hispana si no en general con
relación a la poesía, al margen
del precio o el valor de mercado que
pueda tener.
Lo que sucede, también, es que
por una parte -- yo vengo de --
hice ciencia durante algún tiempo.
Soy biólogo de formación,
hice paleontología siete años,
trabaje 10 años en el área
científica, pero por otra parte,
también me forme como
pastor religioso.
Bueno, sigo siendo creyente,
ya no ejerzo como pastor.
Y entre dios y el diablo,
elegí la poesía, dije, "No,
mejor me voy por la poesía".
No digo quién era dios
ni quién era el diablo.
Pero, ¿qué sucede entre
esos mundos canónicos?
Ambos mundos monolíticos,
canónicos,
excesivamente deshumanizados y
cuando yo comencé a voltear a ver a
la poesía, y eso es algo
que ha comenzado a perderse,
en tanto que el poeta
se queda en las esferas,
su palabra también se
queda en las esferas,
y está lejana de la
condición humana.
Creo, que hubo un poema,
como una canción popular;
porque las canciones populares
herederas del romance tradicional,
son también poemas, y entonces,
creo que los poemas y
la verdadera poesía,
tienen que ser un espejo que
refleje la honda condición humana;
el dolor, la agonía, el humor,
cualquier cosa que nos re humanice,
y nos devuelva la maravilla y el
asombro por la primera vez que uno
comió, vivió, respiro,
o hizo algo.
Ahí hay poesía.
Entonces, lo que sucede,
es que el poeta también,
o algunos poetas se han contaminado
con estos procesos mercadológicos
de ratificación, y están
más preocupados, muchos,
en ser reconocidos como poetas, en
que su personalidad se reconozca,
que su nombre aparezca en
Facebook, en los medios masivos,
cuando su palabra,
es el pan colectivo,
no es comido más que por el mismo.
Ese duro pan es hacia sí
mismo, y hacia su ego.
Yo estoy en contra
totalmente de eso,
y no importan si un buen poema es
publicado en millones de volúmenes,
en Facebook o en una división
de autor, mientras siga tocando,
nos siga tocando, y nos siga
diciendo acerca de lo humano,
creo que ahí hay poesía.
Y la verdad, es que al contrario,
yo pienso que ahora se lee
y se disfruta más poesía,
dada la cantidad de
medios por la que llega.
Eso sí, seguimos siendo una tribu
pequeña, pero honrosamente humana,
y yo creo que mientras haya ese pan,
esté ahí todavía y haya
bollos en el horno del poeta,
pues vamos a seguir
reuniéndonos como ahora, ¿no?
En esta hoguera.
Y creo que eso es lo que tenemos
que seguir haciendo, ¿no?
Bueno, y el valor y el precio del
mercado que lo sigan haciendo ellos,
los mercadólogos, ¿no?
Nosotros tenemos que seguir haciendo
ese pan con las palabras, ¿no?
Para compartirlo.
>> Consuelo.
[ Aplausos ]
>> Consuelo Hernández:
Buenas tardes.
Qué bonito estar aquí
en esta celebración.
Yo creo que tenemos que
diferenciar entre poesía y poema.
Y la poesía no nos ha
abandonado, ni nos abandonara nunca.
La poesía está allí
disponible para todos.
Cuando la persona es
tocada por la poesía,
y es capaz de fusionar esa
intensidad que lo inspira,
y traducirlo en palabras,
entonces nace el poema,
lo que tenemos disponible
de los poetas es el poema,
pero la poesía está
ahí para todos.
Y cualquiera puede acceder a ella,
unos accedemos mediante las
palabras, otros mediante la pintura,
otros mediante la escultura,
el baile, la danza.
Entonces, no creo que la
poesía nos ha abandonado,
y no me preocupa en lo más mínimo
que la poesía se venda o no se
venda, que si hay compromiso
o no con la poesía.
Yo creo, que uno escribe porque
lo disfruta, porque lo ama,
porque eso te da un placer y
una sensación, y una cosa.
Es compulsivo escribir.
Entonces, yo creo que escribir
por compromiso debe ser horrible,
y personalmente no lo hago,
y escribo cuando siento
que quiero escribir.
No sé si estoy en otra onda, pero
la poesía es una cosa intocable,
está en lo -- es irreductible
a cualquier cosa.
El poema es lo que nosotros
tenemos aquí, y cada persona,
cuando escuchamos los poemas,
cada persona se siente tocado,
aunque sea por un verso o por
una línea, por una palabra,
y es normal que así sea,
porque es algo que también,
cada uno lleva dentro,
y por eso estamos aquí,
pasamos una hora oyendo.
Algunas cosas no nos
gustan, otras sí.
Y de pronto, hay una frase
que te hace despertar,
porque es una manera,
la más sublime,
yo creo, de expresión humana.
La poesía no se vende,
pero hoy en día,
yo creo que es el momento en que
la poesía es más popular que
cualquier otro tiempo.
Yo no sé qué país no tiene
ahora un festival de poesía.
El de Medellín, que yo creo que
es el más viejo tiene 27 años ya.
Nosotros aquí, empezamos --
bueno, yo llegue en el '95
aquí, pero empezó en el '92.
Y vas por cualquier parte;
hay un festival de poesía.
El de Nueva York, donde
está la querida amiga Yrene.
Y hay muchísimos festivales
de poesía.
Entonces, esta -- como que abandono
las aulas y se tomó las calles.
Y estoy de acuerdo
contigo, que muchos --
hay el mito de que la poesía es
difícil, y es todo lo contrario,
es la forma más natural y más -- y
que más conecta con el ser humano.
Abandonó las aulas
pero está en la calle,
está recuperando el ágora
de los griegos esa poesía.
>> Rei Berroa: Creo que le avise.
Consuelo, no digáis que agotado
su tesoro de asuntos falta,
enmudeció la lira, podrá no haber
poetas, pero siempre habrá poesía.
Creo que eso resume lo
que tú querías decir.
Tú habías levantado
la mano, por favor.
Mario, tú también, pero
como no había participado.
>> Mario Bencastro: Yo
creo que lo cerraron.
[ Aplausos ]
>> Carmen: Si, buenas
tardes, mi nombre es Carmen.
Yo no escribo poesía,
pero me encanta leerla.
Desde muy niña empecé a leerlo, y
como decía la señora allá atrás,
que cuando tu lees algo y
hay una línea, una frase,
o algo que te llama la atención,
ahí donde te envuelves en el
sentimiento, en la vivencia,
y tú sabes que a veces, cuando
tú sientes algo y dices,
"Yo sola soy la que sufro, yo
sola soy la que siento esto",
pero encuentras una poesía,
y viste una persona que ha
vivido lo mismo o algo parecido.
Y sientes esa atracción a
lo que ha vivido esa persona.
Y ya hay una conexión, ya.
Entonces, la poesía está
ahí donde hay sentimiento,
donde hay palabra,
donde hay tristeza,
donde hay alegría y
donde hay vivencia,
siempre va a haber poesía.
Nada más.
>> Rei Berroa: Y además -- y por
otro lado, la fuerza clave acá,
como le decía el cartero
a Neruda, ¿se acuerdan?
La poesía no es de
quien la escribe,
si no, de quien la necesita.
>> Carmen: ¿Puedo decir
una poesía qué -- ?
>> Rei Berroa: Claro.
Sí, sí, claro.
Por supuesto.
>> Carmen: Que es -- que
cada vez -- muchas gracias --
cada vez que me siento triste, o
cada vez que siento una angustia,
siempre, este poema que lo
leí cuando tenía como seis,
siete años me impactó.
Y en ese tiempo no lo sentía
tanto como lo siento ahora.
Entonces, cada vez que voy
a una maratón de poesía,
siempre me encanta recitarla.
Es de Abraham Perla Lomar, y
se llama Tristitia [fonético].
Un momento, lo tengo escrito.
>> Rei Berroa: Ah sí, sí.
[ Risas ]
Y van a saber por qué, cada vez
que voy a esto, tiene unos --
como que te lleva a un
viaje a tu infancia,
o la primera vez que lo leíste.
Entonces, es un viaje
de emociones, ¿no?
Mi infancia, que fue dulce,
serena, triste y sola,
se deslizo en la faz
de una aldea lejana.
Entre el manso rumor
con que muere una ola,
y el también doloroso
de una vieja campana.
Daba en el mar las notas de
su melancolía, el cielo,
la serena quietud de su belleza,
los besos de mi madre
una dulce alegría,
y la muerte del sol,
una vaga tristeza.
En la mañana azul,
al despertar sentía,
el canto de las olas como una
melodía, y luego el soplo,
denso, perfumado del mar.
Y lo que él me dijera,
aun en mi alma persiste.
Mi padre era callado, y mi madre
era triste, pero la alegría,
nadie me la supo enseñar.
Gracias.
[ Aplausos ]
>> Rei Berroa: Muy bien.
Creo que nos vamos a quedar ahí,
en la alegría nadie
me la supo enseñar.
Voy a invitar a Luis
Alberto Ambrosio [fonético],
para que haga la presentación de la
versión bilingüe de la antología
de los poetas de Washington, D.C.
>> Luis Alberto Ambrosio:
Bueno, muchísimas gracias, Rei.
Muchísimas gracias a la División
Hispánica de la Biblioteca del
Congreso, que siempre nos apoya
en tantos eventos como este.
Para mí, es un honor, un placer,
y estoy sumamente agradecido,
por haber podido editar, o
coeditar con Carlos Parada,
esta antología de poetas hispanos
de Washington D.C. Originalmente,
la publicó la Academia
Norteamericana de Lengua Española,
en su esfuerzo por documentar,
precisamente nuestra historia,
nuestra presencia, nuestra cultura
hispana de los Estados Unidos,
y la presentamos aquí,
en la Biblioteca del
Congreso en el año 2010.
Irónica, porque Al
Pie de la Casa Blanca,
y sin embargo, está bastante negra.
No digo más.
>> Más negra estaba aún.
>> Luis Alberto Ambrosio:
Bueno, en este momento, hoy,
hace unas semanas aparece
una versión bilingüe de la
misma antología.
Un esfuerzo, fundamentalmente de
todos nosotros, dicho sea de paso,
aquí está, precisamente en la
antología esta Consuelo, esta Rei;
poetas de la zona metropolitana
de Washington D.C.,
dicho sea de paso en la zona
metropolitana de Washington D.C. hay
aproximadamente 4 millones
de habitantes,
de los cuales el 25% es hispano.
Y, en esta zona, estuvo por
ejemplo, Juan Ramón Jiménez,
en esta zona se graduó en una
universidad que no está muy lejos
de aquí; George Washington
University;
Caribela Alegría [fonético] a
quien le acaban de dar el premio
Reina Sofía, y cuyo mentor
era Juan Ramón Jiménez,
y como él podría seguir
nombrando muchísimas personas.
Yo, de hecho cuando llegué aquí,
en el año 1968 estuve
aquí con Nicanor Parra,
es un país y en esta biblioteca,
pues estuvo Pablo Neruda,
estuvo Borges, han estado
muchísimas personas y es
impresionante como por ejemplo,
ellos hablan de estar en el templo
de los duendes, de sentirse.
Porque realmente, eso es esta
biblioteca que nos ha apoyado tanto
a todos nosotros.
En esta antología se incluyen 24
poetas de la zona metropolitana de
Washington D.C., pero provenientes
de muchísimas naciones diferentes;
Cuba, República Dominicana,
Colombia, Argentina, y puedo seguir,
tengo que ver los nombres por
supuesto; España -- bueno.
Lo precede un prólogo que
escribí, en el cual documentamos --
parte del prólogo lo
escribí yo, y luego,
un segundo pequeño
estudio de Carlos Parada,
en el que documentamos
toda esta historia.
Toda nuestra presencia
poética en los Estados Unidos.
Y al pie de la Casa Blanca no quiere
decir sometidos por la Casa Blanca,
si no, con el logo
que decía Kennedy,
"Cuando la política corrompe
a la poesía, purifica."
O sea, como un elemento de
protesta, como un elemento de --
por algo Platón nos echó de la
república, por ser confabuladores.
Y ese es el objetivo de
este -- de esta antología.
Se limitó a obviamente
ocho años de poesía,
desde digamos la década --
digamos desde el 2000 al 2010,
porque no podíamos abarcar todo.
Hay muchos poetas que vivieron acá,
pero que luego estaban
en otros lugares,
entonces no podíamos recuperarlos.
Y realmente, también documenta
las actividades que hemos tenido.
O sea, parece mentira
que desde el 2001,
que estuvimos con [inaudible]
pidiéndole que iniciásemos el
maratón de la poesía, aquí
en la Biblioteca del Congreso,
a principios de los años '90,
nosotros organizábamos la
Academia Norteamericana --
perdón, la Academia
Iberoamericana de Poesía,
organizaba la celebración de los
500 años de poesía escrita en
español, en los Estados
Unidos, y lo hacemos todos los --
durante el mes de la hispanidad.
Y documenta, por supuesto, todo lo
que ha hecho el Teatro de la Luna,
una serie de entidades
culturales en esta zona,
en lo que respecta a
la poesía hispana.
Y también, por supuesto, lo que
hacen las universidades, ¿no?
La Universidad de Maryland, muchas
de las universidades de la zona.
Consuelo dirige también allí --
ha empezado a organizar un
festival poético hispano en abril,
Rei con George Mason University.
Cada una de las universidades tiene
departamentos de lenguas modernas,
de español, etc. Muy activos,
y que bueno, nos enorgullecen.
En fin, por supuesto,
la poesía no se vende,
pero si quieren ordenar el
libro está a disposición.
La poesía no se vende, pero cuesta.
Para acabar, voy a cerrar con
el primer poema que sale en la
antología, que resulta ser mío,
porque la hicimos por orden
alfabético, nada más que por eso.
Y se titula, porque creo que
cuadra en este encuentro,
Paisajes de Estados Unidos.
Si cada ladrillo hablara,
si cada puente hablara,
si hablaran los parques,
las plantas, las flores,
si cada trozo de pavimento
hablara, hablarían en español.
Si las torres, los techos, los
aires acondicionados hablaran,
si hablaran las iglesias, los
aeropuertos, las fábricas,
si la historia, si cada
surco de este país hablara,
hablarían en español.
Si los sudores florecieran
con un nombre,
no se llamarían piedras
si no Sánchez, González,
García, Rodríguez o Peña.
Pero, no pueden hablar,
son manos, obras,
cicatrices que por ahora
callan o quizá, ya no.
Ya no. Paisajes de
los Estados Unidos.
Muchísimas gracias.
[ Aplausos ]
>> Rei Berroa: Gracias,
Luis Alberto.
Tenemos suficiente tiempo para
hacer dos rondas, así que Ricardo.
>> Ricardo Ballón: Bueno --
bueno, ya que estamos
caminando por Estados Unidos,
voy a leer un poema a Manhattan.
Con el rio a su cintura, cada puente
es un abrazo lleno de ilusiones o
desdichas por donde cruza el
sol ajeno y despreocupado.
Entre tantos fantasmas
descascarados,
repletos de ventanas lejanas,
y ojos que ni nos miran.
[ Aplausos ]
>> Joao Luís Barreto
Guimaraes: Estatuas --
[ Portugués ]
Estatuas a las que faltan pedazos.
En el ala de arte romano,
ya no sé de qué museo,
se exhiben trozos arcaicos
a los que faltan pedazos,
el tiempo fue meticuloso al
escoger lo que se llevó,
las primeras partes en caer
varían conforme el género,
hay tres gracias sin cabezas,
un dios Febe sin pene.
Debe de haber algún lugar donde
abunde la anatomía que por aquí
sigue faltando.
Bellas cabezas en mármol,
de mala gana la anemia,
falos sueltos sin torso,
tristes y sin empleo.
Agradezcamos a los dioses
el don de la imaginación,
que permite figurar
todo cuanto desfigura.
No es un ejercicio difícil,
no ha sido castigo divino,
no se han roto con el uso.
Gracias.
[ Aplausos ]
>> Mario Bencastro: Bueno,
este es el canto número cinco,
y se lo vamos a dedicar
a Consuelo Hernández,
porque ella vivía en
un tiempo en Nueva York,
y emigro de Nueva York
para esta tierra,
así que ella recordara
estos pasajes,
y seguramente ha entrado en
la Iglesia de la Trinidad.
La oscura Iglesia de la Trinidad
antes se imponía en la niebla,
como faro gigante,
guía de navegantes.
Hoy, se asfixia entre rascacielos,
enormes Torres de Babel,
de una urbe que no duerme.
En la entrada del templo
confluyen tres rutas; Wall Street,
el sendero de la fortuna.
Broadway, la avenida del drama.
Trinidad, el camino de la fe.
Tres vías distintas, que llevan
a un solo destino verdadero;
tumbas de eminentes -- de
eminencia rodean el santuario.
Inventores financieros,
padres de la patria, editores,
peregrinos de rincones lejanos
reducidos a epitafios de mármol.
Flores adornadas por huesos --
flores abonadas por huesos
adornan veredas y monumentos,
donde jóvenes especuladores,
comparten estrategias y
almuerzos con sus antepasados.
"Caminante", advierte un epitafio,
"Reflexiona en que tú también
te irás, pocos piensan en ello,
la vida está llena de dolor,
pero en este lugar
descansaras para siempre,
prepárate para el gran final.
No te fíes de la suerte",
previene otro.
Como una pérfida amante te sonríe
al amanecer, te ama el día entero,
y a las cinco de la tarde, cuando
cierra la bolsa de Wall Street,
como Judas te traiciona,
y te vende al infortunio.
"Despoetízate", amonesta un
poeta, "Contra-poetízate,
libérate de la poesía industrial,
serial, comercial, global,
intervenida, amancillada,
glorificada, nadada",
voces nulas que rebotan en los
remolinos de hombres y papel que
truenan en Wall Street.
Gracias.
[ Aplausos ]
>> Tracy K. Lewis: Me parece
importante representar, también,
a los millones de personas
entre nosotros que hablan
lenguas indígenas.
Entonces, voy a leer
un poema en guaraní,
ustedes no van a entender
ni lo más mínimo,
por eso no van a percibir mis
errores de pronunciación,
mi malísima gramática, y después,
tengo una versión en español.
Esto tiene un título en
inglés, "For Street 101".
Muy pretencioso, ¿tres
lenguas, verdad?
Con gratitud, Miguel Ángel
Mesa P. Huaran [fonético].
[ Idioma extranjero ]
Dejar crecer bosques en la punta
de tu lengua, yuyos, malezas,
marañas de lechos encaramarse en el
aire desgreñado de monos y lianas.
¿Hasta dónde se derrama
tu cabello del pericráneo?
Pulsa tu cerebro como paloma
en las copas arrulladas.
Copulen aves, ranas; abunden.
Lagartos, lujurien en
follaje al pie de árboles,
que ponen sombra a los
ríos donde corre tu sangre,
como agua al Amazonas de tu pensar.
Volvé, volvé, ¿quién te dijo
que no llevás por dentro el Edén?
[ Aplausos ]
>> Elena Medel: Tritanopia
[fonético].
Vuestro odio a los colores
ha acabado con ella,
vuestro odio a lo pagano
y las cuchillas.
[Inaudible] alejándola de su dolor
de estómago es mi estructura,
junto a ella moriré.
Tenis cuanto queríais,
era Alicia, no el diamante.
Ningún destrozo.
Si dabais la espalda,
mordíais muy profundo.
Un mecanismo fácil, una
labor sencilla, tragad.
Despidiendo como si fuese la
última cerveza junto a otro
chico preferido.
Las bombillas son frágiles,
igual que sus hilos termino rota.
Ojos de sapo, mi noche esférica,
cáliz en el saludo,
inevitable vomitar.
Cuanto queríais en
vuestras manos, sois felices.
Lo conseguisteis.
Reencarnados en mujeres
y en hombres,
bailáis con vosotros mismos
mientras se oxida vuestra lengua de
oro falso.
Por el norte pisasteis
charquitos de saliva venenosa,
manchasteis la entrada
al dormitorio.
Os empeñáis en un
nombre del que ella carece.
Llamándola, te quise
siempre, estrecho tu mano,
no conozco otro dolor
que no haya sido nuestro,
lo habéis conseguido,
acabasteis con ella.
En vuestra mesilla de noche, respira
minúscula por no despertaros.
Menos aire, menos aire, pequeña,
tonta, ¿besareis su cadáver?
Gracias.
[ Aplausos ]
>> Balam Rodrigo: De mi
libro, "Sobras Reunidas",
así se llama, aunque no lo crean.
Y por ahí hay -- aparecen
varios poetas; el poeta místico,
el poeta bohemio, el
poeta comprometido,
el poeta de pueblo y otros más.
En fin, leo el del poeta
comprometido, es uno de los breves.
>> Gracias.
>> Balam Rodrigo: El
poeta comprometido,
aprovecha las palabras de la
plebe o las protestas de moda,
para escribir docenas de panfletos,
pero no pueden empuñar un ramo de
amor para sus hijos o los hijos de
los otros.
Poco sabe del hambre o de la
sangre derramada por los poetas
combatientes, que primero fueron
hombres antes que llamarse poetas a
sí mismos.
Porque la mala poesía también
es culpable de que se pierdan
algunas guerras.
Más le valdría tomar la hoz para
segar su nombre de los libros.
Vaya, de Facebook o de Twitter,
y olvidar para siempre
el lápiz o la pluma,
herramientas que no conoce.
Si este guerrillero de escritorio
quisiera realizar un acto
comprometido y revolucionario
en esta vida,
que deje de escribirse a sí mismo,
y se eche a dormir bajo la sombra
del espeso bosque de árboles que no
se talara más para sus libros.
[ Aplausos ]
>> Yrene Santos: Y van pasando los
años, y los -- y se van los papas,
yo digo, cuando mueren, en vez de
morir, yo uso la palabra mudarse,
y se van acabando los tíos,
y ya cuando mi último tío
se mudó, le escribí esto.
Se llama finalmente.
10 de octubre, 04:00 a.m., una
sonrisa, muchos brazos abiertos,
música de viento y andar
con paso apresurado.
Otros, bailando suave la danza de
la bienvenida, del reencuentro.
El último dolor de mi
abuela se ha extinguido,
yace inerte en la cama eterna
que guardará sus huesos,
cuando la piel caduque haciendo
florecer nuevos jardines.
El último dolor de
mi abuela se durmió.
Y en el sueño atravesó
montañas, ríos, océanos,
trillos que lo llevarían al abrazo
interminable que jamás sintió,
desde su primer grito,
cuando vio la luz.
Mi abuela, ella, Yrene, de quien
nunca se supo donde quedo su cuerpo
con olor a gardenias, a la que
nunca vi, a la que nunca toque,
a la que llego hasta mi
solo mientras dormía,
después de escuchar historias
construidas y reconstruidas a
través de la infancia.
Ella, hoy, cierra el círculo
con sus seis amores dentro.
Gracias.
[ Aplausos ]
>> Rei Berroa: Última ronda.
Qué triste.
>> Ricardo Ballón: Con
el permiso de todos --
con el permiso de todos ustedes,
mis poesías son tan pequeñas
que voy a juntar unas cuantas.
[ Risas ]
Ya.
>> Unas cuantas.
>> Ricardo Ballón: En la medida
cinco, siete y cinco nace un Haiku.
A nuestro lado, por todo
el camino, sigue la luna.
El relámpago prende la
luz del cielo atormentado.
Dulces sonrisas en los
pequeños labios, las mandarinas.
Como dos barcos, esos zapatos
viejos cruzan los charcos.
Voy a dedicar uno a mi
señora, que está presente.
Guau.
Si. Muy nervioso, porque
se me perdieron --
si los veía, estos son
del siguiente poeta.
>> Mételo preso.
>> Ricardo Ballón: Puerta, puerto.
Todos somos parte.
Lega el parto, tu madre
se parte, y tú partes.
Ay, hijo, no soy mar, no
soy lago, simplemente río.
Ríe.
>> Que bueno.
>> Ricardo Ballón: Para cerrar;
los recuerdos por más
alegres que sean, lloran.
[ Aplausos ]
>> Joao Luís Barreto
Guimaraes: No sé si Rei.
También dice que soy médico, no.
No dice, ¿dice?
>> Por eso no te gusta Pepsi.
>> Joao Luís Barreto Guimaraes: No,
pero, soy -- también soy cirujano.
Confesión a hipócritas de coz.
Me acuerdo de aquella vez,
cuando trate a un carpintero.
Sobre la mesa de operar,
nada más que lo habitual,
quien nos viera trabajando
a mi colega y a mí,
diría que la danza técnica
iba a la perfección,
los dedos de la mano enferma
tantas veces tan maltratados,
eran más lo que faltaron
que los dedos por segar.
Nunca más saqué la mano,
podría hacer otro stop.
Celebrar una victoria, o
¿costar con el dedo del medio?
Debajo de la mesa, sin embargo,
ocurría lo que voy a contar;
la rodilla de ella quedo entre mis
rodillas, escuchen, estoy seguro.
Se bien que fue un instante,
pero tengo casi la certeza,
algo allí parecía vivo, el fuego
de aquel instante aun hoy lo siento.
Pasados tantos años
aún arde su ausencia,
como el muchacho dice que
siente y cree aunque lo creo,
la punta de los dedos segados.
Gracias.
[ Aplausos ]
>> Mario Bencastro: Bueno, y este
es el canto número seis, o sexto.
Y con este, como es el ultimo --
>> No se lo digas a nadie.
>> Mario Bencastro:
No te lo dedico a ti.
Va dedicado a Rei Berroa,
porque es el rey, ¿no?
Y todos nosotros somos sus
vasallos, así que algo le debemos.
Y él es el rey de la
poesía, el del maratón.
El río, es unidad y pluralidad.
Cauce y encausado, larga sierpe
de cristal, afinidad, oscuridad,
espuma, raudal, desbordado al
principio y al final del planeta.
Reducto de la totalidad de la nada,
confluencia de soberbios torrentes,
tímidos riachuelos, espejo de
astros, de águilas, ruiseñores,
reflejo de humanos e inhumanos.
¿Qué secretos alberga
esta senda fluvial?
¿Qué amor imposible
impulsa su ruta?
¿Qué desaforado deseo
rige su andar?
¿Qué sinfonía marca el
ritmo de su carroza de peces,
flores y resaca?
Por sus aguas, navegan
humildes balsas,
imponentes cruceros cargados
de vivos y muertos, desechos,
alimentos, amantes y amados.
Es indiferencia y bondad,
provee su causa,
su cauce por igual
a lo que viene y va.
Soberbios señoríos lo navegan,
guerreros con nombres de pájaros,
flores y serpientes, conquistadores
de mágicas metrópolis,
raptores de bellezas, de doncellas
ofrecidas a dioses de la luna y el
sol, labrados en exóticos códices,
imponentes pirámides, estelas,
huellas, montículos
de barro, piedra.
Estáticos vigías de
cementerios, musgos, museos,
tratado de antropología
en el idioma del vencedor.
Por la corriente retumba la potencia
de turno, conquistadores de la luna,
nauta de pájaros metálicos,
pulverizadores de pueblos
milenarios,
héroes de juegos electrónicos,
gozo de infantes, soldados
del futuro.
¿Qué nuevo planeta, que nuevo
poderío surcará el rio mañana?
Gracias.
[ Aplausos ]
>> Tracy K. Lewis: Rei me cogió
de sorpresa con estas dos rondas no
anticipadas, así que casi
al azar, escogí este poema.
Así que -- tiene el
titulo un poco raro;
Limitaciones de la sinécdoque.
[ Risas ]
Mi pene no soy yo, ni mi ombligo,
ni mi bigote, ni mi hígado,
ni mi cerebro, ni los lunares que
pueblan la llanura de mi piel.
Este poema no soy yo, ni la
sopa de tomate que hice anoche,
ni la clase que enseñé
sobre Rubén y Martí,
ni mi cepillo de dientes.
Ninguno de ellos soy, sino todos.
Y todo el conjunto de luciérnagas
que veo en las noches de canícula,
y tú, y el taxista que me llevo
una vez al aeropuerto en San Juan,
y cada mano que mece la cuna
de este ser, siempre naciente.
[ Aplausos ]
>> Elena Medel: A Virginia,
madre de dos hijos,
compañera de primaria de la autora.
Ocupáis tres asientos frente a mí
en el autobús que se desplaza desde
nuestro barrio, alejado del centro,
al centro de nuestra localidad
minúscula, entiéndase,
no al centro de las cosas,
no a la esencia misma,
ni a la materia nuclear
donde la vida va,
donde la vida se expande y obedece
a todos los fenómenos, etcétera,
que dicta la astrofísica.
Lo proclaman la asignatura
que rodeábamos,
porque éramos de letras,
lo proclaman los inexpugnables
mecanismos que atañen a vocablos
tan comunes como universo,
vida, muerte, amor.
Ocupáis tres asientos frente a mí
en la parte trasera del transporte
público, el niño a la derecha,
en el centro la niña,
la madre a la izquierda.
Ahora, tu, hija pequeña de
Virginia, chándal rosa gastado,
igual que los plumeros de tu madre,
con un personaje que mi edad
y condición soltera ignoran.
Ahora, tu, hijo mayor de Virginia,
intuyo en tu barbilla y tus orejas
los rasgos que heredaste de tu
padre, y me pregunto,
¿si Virginia lo maldice?
Virginia lo maldice a la
hora del baño, pero tú,
Virginia, tan rubia, lo recuerdas.
Allá donde entonces
combatíamos piojos, ahora van,
ahora escondemos el tiempo.
Aquí, tu lees una revista
Virginia, aquí tu no me reconoces,
te sirven los consejos del cuche,
o tú, tan rubia e inocente.
Virginia, siempre con mi
edad, y ahora con dos hijos,
sin anillo en el dedo, con un
bolso colmado de galleta, Virginia,
hijo mayor de Virginia,
hija pequeña de Virginia.
Años luz caídos, años luz
quebrados en la comisura de
los labios.
Cerrad los ojos y pedid
un deseo frente a mí,
en el autobús destartalado que nos
salva del barrio periférico y nos
acerca al centro, lejos de los
bancos en los que los adolescentes
beben, y las noches golpean los
jardines, cierra los ojos, Virginia,
porque en nuestros 28 minutos de
trayecto he pensado en nosotras,
en ti, que no me reconoces
20 años más tarde.
En tus canas donde la
gente que nunca te hablo,
en tus canas donde la
gente ríe, y se burlaba.
Cristal del autobús
junto a Virginia.
Espejito de ambas.
Tus uñas rojas, comidas
al fregar los platos.
Una gota de laca roja
en tu dedo anular,
oh Virginia, oh rubia e inocente.
Yo he pensado en nosotras, van.
Yo he pensado en nosotras.
No sé si sabes a lo que me refiero.
Te estoy hablando del fracaso.
Gracias.
[ Aplausos ]
>> Balam Rodrigo: A partir de
otra fotografía de Diane Arbus,
bueno es el único mexicano
que fotografió a un enano,
no sé porque me identifico
con la fotografía.
Bueno, al menos fotografió a uno.
Inciso A. El aire golpea las
ventanas del cuarto como el tambor
del corazón, mordido
por la rabia del mar,
un pedazo de cedro en el bolsillo
para recordar el olor del trópico.
Los muslos morenos de las
muchachas en la playa,
el color del salitre avanzando por
los muros del puerto de Veracruz,
como la sangre de toros de Lidia
tiñendo las piedras de Tlacotalpan.
Aquí no hay palmeras ni arena,
solo nieve y sed entre la sangre.
Un machetazo de vodka
me parte la garganta,
calienta mi pecho, y
ahuyenta mi sombra.
Afuera, luna rota, cielo en
estrellas de rojo vidrio,
nubes resquebrajadas.
A 20 pisos de altura, mientras
los barcos aúllan a la noche,
como perros sarnosos en los muelles.
Ella me abraza tres veces, con
la lumbre de su carne desnuda.
Inciso B. Diane me trajo un Panamá
de filtro, una botella de ron,
cigarrillos de tabaco negro
y un beso para la fiebre.
Domados de la sombra, salimos del
hotel y vagamos por las calles,
resollando silencio
como bestias de humo.
En las aceras deambulan
ejércitos insomnes, gatos,
y palomas de hollín, adolescentes
que escriben fuego de jeringuillas
en el sucio cuaderno de sus brazos,
antiguas matronas maquilladas
por la muerte,
rancios caballeros vestidos con
trajes de orine y corbatas de mugre.
Canto en voz alta, dios nunca muere,
y las paredes me devuelven el
eco y su lenguaje de asfalto.
Bajo el imperio de su cámara,
y atado al yugo de su carne,
soy un príncipe enano, investido
con una corona y un manto de nieve.
A lo lejos, se escuchan los primeros
ladridos de la luz, amanece,
brilla en el cielo
una estrella negra.
Inciso C. Pienso en
la espalda de Diane,
y un relámpago de cedro
atraviesa mi lengua.
Inciso D. Enanos entre los
rascacielos de Nueva York,
somos insignificantes bufones,
actuando un efímero y burdo papel
en la eterna puesta en escena del
Teatro Guiñol de la vida, con un
único y gigante libreto; el dolor.
[ Aplausos ]
>> Yrene Santos: Y me
toca cerrar, ¿sí?
Gracias otra vez, Rei.
Gracias a todos estos
poetas maravillosos.
Gracias por esta tarde exquisita,
gracias Consuelo, por estar aquí.
Los amo. Estos son los
recuerdos que nos llevamos,
la poesía siempre vivirá a pesar
de todo, porque la llevamos dentro.
A pesar de que las
personas a veces nos digan,
"Yo no entiendo nada de lo que
leíste, yo no entiendo nada de eso.
Yo no entiendo".
A pesar de que la poesía,
cuando publiqué mi primer libro,
en el '88, me dijo mi
prima donde yo vivía,
para asistir a la universidad,
"Yo fui, pero yo no entiendo nada,
nada de lo que tú estás
diciendo ahí" y yo, bueno.
Pero, estamos expuestos
a todas estas respuestas.
Entonces -- pero lo más importante
es que la llevamos con nosotros y
que siempre existirá.
Y para mí, comentaba con
Lima, la señora Lima --
Alicia, sí que cuando escribimos,
algunas personas piensan que --
muchas personas me han dicho
directamente, "A mí no me --
yo no busco que nadie me entienda,
que a mí no me importa
si me entienden.
Yo no quiero llevarle
nada a nadie", pero,
yo si pienso que la poesía
sirve para curar mucho.
Y que aunque no le guste mi poesía,
"Basta", le decía yo a Alicia.
Con que un solo verso de lo
que yo escribo toque a alguien,
para mí es suficiente.
La poesía siempre va a vivir.
Y cierro con esto.
20 de mayo.
¿Cómo hacer el amor con un volcán
que amanece con robarse el aire?
Cuando horizontal, derrama con rubor
todos los pálpitos en cada orilla
de la piel, los huesos, y se cuaja
la sangre con su placer anaranjado.
¿Cómo recibir el amor que en
lenguas geométricas envuelve la
cintura, el pecho, las
extremidades y la garganta misma?
Que trata de exhalar
lo más que pueda,
antes de que el aire se
ausente en un grito silencioso,
extraño y doloroso.
¿Cómo dar todo ese amor?
Si el volcán no deja
que lo abrace, lo bese.
Solo recibe las miradas porque hay
momentos en que prefiere regalar
todo su fuego con los ojos abiertos.
Así sabe que entra, que
camina y acelera su paso,
cruzando los vecindarios que
rodean la laringe, el esófago,
y siente que todo convulsiona
a gusto,
cuando llega al diafragma la mirada.
¿Cómo respirar?
¿Cómo repetir las erupciones?
Si la lluvia ha sido grande, espesa,
y un río ha nacido en cada hueco
y ha desembocado en el océano,
que solo tu cuerpo y el
de ella han conocido.
¿Cómo será desenredar
estos caminos recorridos,
este océano que es de ellos,
del volcán y la sabana?
¿Cómo deshacer estas aguas,
para volver al principio
de todos los principios?
Muchas gracias.
[ Aplausos ]
>> Rei Berroa: Y con esto, cerramos
esta primera parte del 25 Maratón
de la Poesía del Teatro de la Luna.
Muchas gracias, poetas.
Muchas gracias, público.
Y nos vemos mañana, en el Centro
Cultural de la Embajada de España,
para la segunda sesión
del maratón,
que va desde las 2:00 p.m.,
a las 8:00 p.m., sin parar.
Por eso, se llama maratón.
Gracias, poetas.
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.